so welcome everyone thank you for making
it today and a very busy day and in
their very busy but
classes this is the last climate science
seminar from the YC I for this semester
we have four additional ones on the
screen but the last one for this
semester and we're very happy to have yo
[ __ ] Christensen here today from
University of Oslo he is currently on
sabbatical adding car so he had a
shorter travel than he would have
otherwise yo [ __ ] got his PhD from the
university of bergen an excellent place
to study meteorology as many well know
afterwards he worked at the new engine
met office for a little while then went
to do a postdoc at Los Alamos National
Lab and then after that he took a
faculty position at University of Oslo
and has been there since for 21 years he
just told me you know you also was my
PhD advisor and has been a tremendous
mentor to me for more than a decade now
actually some are he happy to have him
here today he's going to talk to about
climate engineering how common
engineering could influence the
hydrological cycles is cut both EU
funding and Norwegian funding to do work
on engineering and that's quite quite
rare there's not much funding for that
kind of work right now so we'll hear
about some of that today and you may get
to take it away Thank You true thats
really good to be here and good to see
you again I've been very fortunate to
have some good students through the
years and true there's a prime example
of that and it's my first time here at
Yale and the topic today I mean I've
worked on many topics of the years and I
got into this through my interest in air
so cloud interactions climbed
engineering of course is a very
complicated topic in a lot of ways and
as many political aspects and
philosophical moral aspects so I I'm
happy to discuss that with you but but
the main focus of my talk will be on the
Natural Science aspects of this but I
will also touch on some of those other
disciplines that are involved and in
fact the you trace project which has its
logo there at the top Wars just ended a
couple of days ago in fact it's an
eu-funded project and that is a European
transdisciplinary assessment of climate
engineering so that's a very broad
project in terms of disciplines and
that's really required in order to deal
with a topic like this because it
involves so many aspects from from
governance to to moral issues and of
course technology and Natural Science
okay but but today I will so I will give
you an overview of clandestine that and
then I will narrow it down a little bit
to have a special attention or focus on
the hydrological cycle which I think in
many ways is the most important aspect
of climate change in general that I
think humans can adapt to changes in
temperature to a significant extent but
big changes in the availability of
moisture I think are much more
challenging to people and that's why I
think it's a key question whether we
took with global warming or climate
engineering and I'd like to acknowledge
my co-authors Helena Murray who's with
me in oskaloosa postdoc and focus mitts
in Hamburg whom I'm collaborated with
any who also led the implicit okay so
why are we sitting here or standing here
now talk about climate engineering I
guess you all know why this has been
coming up over the last few years with
growing interest and and one way of
thinking about that is through this
figure I got from a colleague in Oslo at
Cicero and what this figure shows is
what it would take in terms of emissions
to meet the two degree target and of
course there are many ways to calculate
this and you make it slightly different
results based on how you do that but I
think qualitatively speaking I think
this is this a sort of state-of-the-art
results we're seeing here
and the point being that this here is
the temperature change based on sort of
typical climate sensitivity assumptions
so if you want to end up around two
degrees at the end of the century you
really need to bring the emissions down
to these colored lines here and this
would mean this kind of evolution of
global co2 emissions and this kind of
evolution of the co2 concentration
alternatively if we if we follow these
gray lines which maybe might look a
little bit more realistic I don't know
hopefully not well then we're not a two
degrees then we're getting close to four
degrees so it just gives an idea of what
a challenge it is to really move meet
the two degree target of course you can
say well it's an arbitrary turkey then
maybe it is but facility gives an idea
of I'm A two degrees global is something
like five or six degrees in the Arctic
so it is a very dramatic change so the
question is okay if it's that hard and
we're still on a business-as-usual
pathway is this really going to happen
are we going to do this and I certainly
hope we will but at least it's enough
back want to motivate that maybe we
should at least know what climate
engineering is and whether it really is
an option and whether it and what it how
it might work if we were ever to
consider using it and the scientific
motivation for believing that it might
work is that we have these natural
experiments climbed it in ear
experiments every now then when our
planet decides to spew out huge amounts
of so2 into a stratosphere and cooled
down the Earth's climate and this of
course has happened several times over
the Earth's history to a varying degree
the latest and best documented of these
eruptions was the Pinatubo eruption 1991
which cooled down your client by about
half a degree
of course it's only temporary cooling
because the residence time is about two
years so these particles but still it's
a very consistent signal that we see for
all these major eruptions so the
question could we deliberately inject
particles like this into sort of here to
get the same effect continuously and
that may not be as easy as it sounds
because if you you can get if you try to
if you need a large cooling you would
need to inject a lot of so2 and/or
precursor gas and then you start getting
coagulation between these particles so
that that they fall out more rapidly and
so they're all sort of issues here it's
not easy or maybe not even possible but
that's what we want to find out so I
will start by and I guess I've started
it already saying a little bit about the
principles of climate engineering and
then I will talk a little bit about what
we could just general thoughts on solar
radiation management what it means to
cancel co2 long way forcing by reducing
solar shortwave forcing it turns out
that that's not a really good
consolation there and one of the
implications is that we get as a side
effect that we get a weakening of the
hydrological cycle and this is a robust
result from from many or system models
and then the question is okay if this
happens in the most sort of generic
experiment could there be other ways of
doing client-attorney which might avoid
this weakening of the hydrological cycle
for instance if we do something with
clouds instead and then also how can we
understand why does this happen can we
can I understand this results from a
atmospheric energetics perspective okay
first a little bit about the different
climate engineering techniques that have
been proposed and
this nice cartoon here came out five
years ago so it doesn't contain
everything but it contains many of the
the main ideas that have been proposed
and in red here are circled those that
deal with what we call solar radiation
management were the idea is to reduce
the amount of solar radiation that
reaches the Earth's surface and thereby
to cool there's climate to counteract
the warming by greenhouse gases so this
can be either like I've already
mentioned and stratosphere road can even
be outside the atmosphere by sun shades
or mirrors in space or it can be in the
troposphere if we can manipulate the
cloud so they reflect more solar
radiation or the surface albedo even and
then in blue here we have greenhouse gas
removal which which goes beyond the
ordinary carbon capture and
sequestration so these are more vigorous
ways of trying to get rid of greenhouse
gases and I'm not going to talk very
much about these in this talk but but
most of these are the way it looks now
from a current knowledge this is not an
easy solution this would of course be
rather uncontroversial solution compared
to some of these but but it turns out
they are typically very expensive and
not very effective from our current
understanding so it's not it's co2 is
not an easy molecule to just describe
from the atmosphere and then one that is
not mentioned here with s'true de of
course is an expert on is this one was
first proposed but they admit show a few
years ago is so this is not solar
radiation management because this is
long wave terrestrial radiation
management and the idea is to make this
cirrus clouds thinner the circuit clubs
that have a warming a net warming effect
on the Earth's climate because they they
they trap a long way radiation they also
reflection solar radiation but the long
wave effect tends to dominate by a
factor of two or so and the idea is that
you would I'll come back to the mitral
physics here but
with true that probably has explained to
you before anyway but but the idea is
that by proceeding by a proper material
ice nuclei you would deplete the cloud
you'd get a cloud with fewer and larger
ice crystals which would fall out and
okay so what is actually going on her
let's just take a broad perspective here
on the energy balance of the climate
system so if the climate is stable it
means that the amount of energy coming
in and going out is about the same and
that would be with a current climate
something like 240 watts per meter
squared and we can express this as the
solar constant there were 4 times 1
minus T or so be Rho equal to sigma x
the effective radiated temperature to
the power of 4 so and what happens if we
double co2 is that we and if we now just
focus on the effect of co2 itself and
not the temperature change then we would
be reducing the outgoing radiation about
3.7 watts per meter squared and then the
climb sister would warm up to get back
to that new radiator balance but if we
instead of letting it warm up if we try
to restore the balance by by force we
can use one of these methods here we can
either reduce the income solar radiation
that's s or we can enhance the
reflectivity the alpha or we can enhance
the outcome long radiation like in the
search cloths inning so there are
different ways of addressing this
equation here
and then like I said before there are
many disciplines involved when integral
climate engineering and so I will mainly
talk about this one climate science and
the questions were asking climate
science well climate engineering is
would it work and how effective would it
be and what would the side effects be of
course we don't know it may well be that
we find oh yeah it works but then the
engineers tell us no it doesn't because
we can do it so that's another aspect we
have to consider or the Philosopher's
will tells no no people will never
accept it so it doesn't matter if it
works or not so all these disciplines
have their own leto right so to speak or
it could be that we cannot agree on how
to handle it how to regulate it like who
is responsible if it fails and how
should be regulated and also it could be
that oh yeah that all this is fine but
it's just too expensive so we won't do
it for that reason so there are many
aspects that need to be considered and
I'm just going to have one more slide on
that and that is on the should we even
do the research on this at all log onto
am I a bad person that I've don't reset
Oakland is he said an immoral thing to
do maybe it is maybe it is and there are
some good bright people that think we
shouldn't do this for good reason one of
the arguments is the so-called moral
hazard argument which means that by
doing research on this but climate
scientists we are drawing attention of
people around us from emission
reductions because we give we given the
impression that there's an easy way out
that you don't need to worry about
global warming we're going to fix it so
it's a it's a distraction and that's a
good argument but one can also argue
against that and I would argue but I'm
happy to to discuss it if you disagree
with me
I would argue that it's also important
that we scientists who don't have an
agenda get involved in this research so
that it gets done in as neutral and
objective way as possible and then the
other argument against the research is a
slippery slope argument that oh yeah we
scientists of course only want the best
for mankind but but it could be that
other people will take over the
politicians or technology will take our
knowledge and use it in a manner that we
had not envisaged or recommended that's
also an important argument and but one
can also argue against that by maybe
saying that well this is sort of
assuming that we will find a way to do
this but we don't know that maybe our
research research will do the opposite
maybe we will find that it doesn't work
I mean certainly we don't I'm not trying
to promote slammed engineering I'm just
exploring it so yeah so these are big
questions okay so so that was sort of my
introduction and now I'll go into the
more of the Natural Science aspects here
and first just a review or some of these
techniques what they are about and what
are the principles first this mirrors in
space and I think a lot of people
consider this one to be quite far
fetched and likely to be very risky and
very expensive but but there are people
pursuing this like this angel guy who
had this paper in pnas few years ago and
the idea is that at the Lagrangian point
in space where where you have sort of
balance between the forces so if you put
something there it will stay this were
the solar satellite is you could put
some reflective mirrors which would
reduce the solar radiation even before
it hits the atmosphere
here and and one of the main model
experiments that I will show you in a
few minutes it's actually based on this
idea not because we think it's a
realistic idea but because it's an easy
experiment to make so that we can have a
lot of models involved and get abroad
and sample of models and the gym if it's
the geoengineering model intercomparison
project and this particular experiment
is called g1 as sort of the the most
basic experiment the way it works is
that first you have a control run with
your earth system model then at a
particular point in time you
simultaneously quadruple the co2
concentration and reduce the solar
constant accordingly so that the
radiative forcing so there's no ready to
force thing no not forcing so that they
cancel each other and you have to do
some I turati you cannot know in advance
exactly how much you need to reduce it
varies from model to model so you need
some iteration but but you can figure
that out and then you can do the
experiment and you get so it's basically
no net force it so there's also the no
feedbacks or greatly suppressed feedback
so it's a nice experiment from that
point of view and then moving into
somewhat more maybe realistic ideas this
is of course the basic idea that stems
from the volcanic eruptions and the one
that paul crutzen proposed in is 2006
paper and climatic change we sort of got
this debate going on climate engineering
so the idea is to mimic the major
volcanic eruptions to somehow get either
particles are particle precursors into
satisfier so that they would fall so
form sulfate aerosols which would then
reflect solar radiation and and there
are many different methods and injection
methods and that having considered but
and so this cartoon here by a la ropa
illustrates some of that balloons air
craft rocket even towers so we don't
know what will be most realistic or
efficient if this ever were to be tried
but what we know already from model
simulations is there there's a
well-documented side effects like
sorcery ozone depletion seems to be an
issue when we finally fix the
stratosphere we're going to start
messing around with it again also there
are some issues with changes the
precipitation especially if this were
not done uniformly over the whole globe
it depends that depends on the how
exactly it's deployed and then if we
move into the troposphere this is
another idea that's been around for a
while since 1990 by John Latham and we
know that these low clouds over the
subtropics they have a strong cooling
effect on climate because they have they
have a relatively large albedo they're
quite extensive and they are there all
the time almost and at the same time
they are and the surface albedo is very
low where they'll be to the cloud this
may be eighty percent if you take away
the cloud you have only a five percent
albedo the surface and there's and the
Sun is high these latitudes at the same
time since they are in the boundary
layer their emission temperature is is
really high almost like that the surface
so they have basically no longer in fact
just the strong negative short wave
effect so this is strong and cooling
effect so if we could somehow make these
clouds even more extensive or even more
reflective than then and the idea here
is to suck up sea water by some vessel
here and then to inject sea spray into
the atmosphere which went evaporates it
leaves behind sea salt particles that
get sucked into the updrafts and and get
go into the clouds and make the clothes
more reflective
as side effect here are not it's well
known I mean this is something that I've
been concerned about that that these are
relatively small regions we're thinking
about which we would reduce the income
of sunlight tremendously so I would
think that it could disrupt marine
ecosystems but I don't I haven't seen
any study of that so this is it's just a
thought and then there's so that's about
brightening the clouds how about
brightening the surface and the desert
who cares about the desert why don't we
just make them a little bit brighter it
seems like an easy target that make the
Sahara Desert covered with some very
reflective material I mean it's already
a wasteland so with the hug but the
albedo is not very high actually so if
you could somehow get their leader to be
like a little snow it would make a huge
impact and and there have been some
studies of this and yeah it has an
impact but there's an undesired side
effect that seems to be emerging from
these studies and this figure here
illustrates that because what happens
here when you're cooling when a imposing
this cooling effect over land is that
you get sinking motion that you can sing
commotion over land and then you get the
secretary circulation with rice emotion
of the oceans so what you're essentially
doing is that you're making the desert
even more extensive which is not really
what you want because most people live
on land and we need all the
precipitation we can get over low
latitude land regions in that sense this
if I this is a method here would be
better because there's the opposite here
you're cooling down the oceans of you
getting more cloud formation over land
oh come back to that okay then how about
cirrus cloud thing here the idea is to
inject a fish and ice nuclei into the
regions where cirrus clouds form and
these search loves have a strong or have
a net warming effect as I've said before
so the idea is that you would force a
transition from homogeneous freezing
naturally to heterogeneous freezing and
if you inject the right number of ice
nuclei would not the number is not too
high then you will get fuel and larger
ice crystals an optically thin a cloud
and you would get a stronger outgoing
long-wave radiation and here also the
side effects are not well known people
often ask me about this so I'll put it
up there toxic effects of bismuth may be
true that has some thoughts on that I
don't know and but a big question is
also when where and how to inject and
another truth has also looked into that
so this is maybe the most recent and
least explored of these may four main
techniques okay so these are the
techniques and and now I'm coming to the
question that I'm interested in this
talk in particular and that's the
hydrological cycle not the temperature
we know we can cool down the planet but
what are the side effects associated
with that and one reason why we might
expect that they would be side effect is
that we see if we just look the spatial
and temporal patterns or co2 forcing and
solar forcing they are not they don't
match so if we try to cancel this
bye-bye that it's not going to be a
clean consolation so that's just an
indication hmm it's not so simple and it
turns out that it isn't that simple and
so results from these d1 experiments
show that that there are systemic
changes in the hydrological cycle and I
will just work you through why that or
how the place out first they said the
net radiative flux when we are reducing
a quadrupling co2 by a reduction of
solar constant so globally averaged zero
but it's not zero
everywhere it's actually quite strong
and negative in the tropics and positive
at high latitudes so it wouldn't be
wouldn't say the Arctic sea ice but at
least it would reduce the warming of
course so this is the the residual
warming so the residual warm have high
latitude but actually cooling at low
latitudes but the point is that most of
the evaporation is taking place at low
latitudes so precipitation would be
reduced almost everywhere so we see that
we have a lot of red and yellow her we
don't have much blue so this is really
skewed to the negative side as opposed
to the temperature this is the global
average here is zero the global ours
here is zero the global ours here is
some log minus five percent and the
implication of that is one way to look
at that is through the Bowen ratio that
ratio between sensible and latent heat
that we see in a lot of regions which an
increase in the bone rates are
indicating a drawing of the land regions
there are also other ways to look at
this but qualitatively they show the
same thing and there are some exceptions
Australia actually has a moistening but
but a lot of drying over land regions
but of course we should also keep in
mind that four times co2 is not a good
idea either so this is actually even
worse in terms of drawing of land
regions especially in the Indus approach
where the desert regions are spreading
and becoming larger okay so back to
another global pitch okay so so what is
going on here so this is now an example
of these models that took part in this
experiment so there's one simple for
each model here and we have temperature
changed on the y-axis precipitation
change on the x-axis and and this is so
we start with pre industrial conditions
1850 and then we do four times co2 and
we had
here so we get warmer and wetter okay
but then we balance the 4th and co 2 pi
by turn down the solar constant so we
get a temperature change which is zero
but as I mentioned before the
precipitation change is not zero in fact
all the mods agree on this so it can't
be just a fluke that there's a badly
parameterised hydraulic in one of the
models all a month agree on this so this
is a fundamental or at least a general
result among the models and it turns out
that it this is actually something that
people have been thinking about for a
while and have explained and for
instance there was this paper by Alan
Ingram nature 12 years ago where they
were thinking about the same kind of
question but notice how to climb the
engineering but in terms of global
warming and they looked at the climate
models at the time and the hydrological
cycle and this is sort of one triangle
here for each model and this is the red
line is then an average or best fit of
these models and we see that even for a
temperature change of 1.4 degrees
there's no increase in precipitation and
this is the clausius-clapeyron line and
this one actually is a good
approximation to held the amount of
water vapor in the atmosphere changes
but in terms of the precipitation
doesn't follow the same rules
precipitation does not go by clutter
clutter and like humidity does it goes
by some other rule it has a weaker
dependency and why is that and if you of
course this is not what they did this my
thinking or if you were just too
extrapolating you would again get
something like five percent for a zero
temperature change so so let's let's
look at some equations i'm not going to
show you a lot of equation but but we
need an equation for the
energetics of the atmosphere energy
budget of the atmosphere and and I mean
the way it works at the atmosphere is
not an energy I mean it's in energy
balance but it's not in radiative
balance because there's more than just
radiation contributing and reality that
the radiation is systematically a
cooling effect but this is then balanced
by release of latent heat and sensible
heat from the surface we're latent he
dominates and we can express this by
this equation here so the atmosphere the
change in other heat content is given by
the surface fluxes plus the radiative
flux divergence which is the difference
between and then netted downwelling tub
atmosphere mindNet del willing at the
surface okay so how how does this
equation help us and now let's think
about perturbing this equation but so
some change either climate change or
climate engineering or and so we said
put deltas then on all the terms here
and then now I solve the equation for
the surface fluxes that I'm interested
in and if we now for a moment think
about that the climate this hasn't had
time to change much as a response to the
perturbation we're looking for the fast
response let's like in the model
simulation where we spontaneously
increased co2 but the fluxes have a time
to change because that's instantaneous
so the outgoing long-wave radiation is
increasing at the same time the
downwelling long radiation is also
increasing but it turns out that if we
if we're adding more co2 then this term
will be larger than that one or that
change will be lot on that change and
that's important because it means that
so we're reducing this positive term
here and then we're we're increase in
this one but much less than we're
decreasing this one and this one is zero
so so all know we're reducing the late
heat flux if we add more co2 and keep
the temperature constant and if we
reduce the latent heat plus we also
reduce in precipitation so this is a
fundamental property of co2 the co2
inflows of the atmosphere in this manner
yeah yeah that's yeah that's that's a
great question i mean in models this is
typically done by keeping the SST
constant what I have done in in
simulations i will show you is that we
look at the first year of the simulation
which turns out that already the first
year the temperature is starting to
change so yeah i guess maybe the first
month might be more appropriate but yeah
but at least first years maybe an
approximation that that has been used in
the literature and when we are using
that and but then of course if you then
go further in time then the slow
response or the feedbacks were still
kicking in and and then that after well
let's start to dominate and the climate
system doesn't care anymore what forcing
it was that that course the perturbation
is just the response that the kilometers
of own dynamics that determined the
nature of the response and then a warmer
climate a lot of these terms start
changing but it turns out that that this
the change of this term outcome long
radiation the top of the atmosphere
dominates and that means that you get an
increase you get a positive perturbation
you're going to increase and latent heat
you can increase in precipitation and
then if you add these two together the
first response of the slow response you
you will find a year if you if you
doubled or increase co2 you will get an
increase in precipitation and that's
because the the warming effect but the
increase will be smaller than you might
think for instance compared to another
type of forcing because of this
a particular way the co2 leads has a
stronger effect the top of the
atmosphere than at the surface which
again is related to how co2 is well
mixed in the atmosphere and it over left
with water vapor in such a way that
because mostly water vapors in lower
troposphere so that's way the effect of
the surface this effect tends to be
rather small where's this one tends to
be large because in the stratosphere
there's no water vapor so co2 has a
strong I said there okay so so so that
sort of some of the principles here now
let's look at what are the simulation
showing us for the hydrological cycle
for these different methods and now I'm
going to focus a little bit about these
on these two methods that deal with
clouds I guess because that's my closest
to my heart so let's first look at
Marine Club writing and I mentioned this
before that marine Claude brightening is
a postal antler brightening and they
have this actually favorable side effect
that it may enhance precipitation over
land at least from these kinds of
arguments you would might expect that
and it turns out that that's sort of
true and and this is from a paper we had
where we had three models so also the
figures of GR averages of results on
three our system models and first of all
we're looking here at the change and top
of the atmosphere net radiation where
we've brightened all the low marine
clouds at low latitudes and as a result
of that we get these strong negative
forces over the subtropics but we see
that we also get a compensating positive
forcing over low latitude land regions
and and if we take a look at this along
a latitude you take a cross-section we
see that there's a tendency for this is
omega here now so the blue is rising
motion anomaly and yellow is a sinking
motion anomaly so we see that tends to
be there are some exceptions but it has
to be rising a perturbation of Alanta
thinking over ocean in many cases not in
all cases in both hemispheres we see the
weapon of blue over land and yellow / /
ocean here which is consistent with that
that argument I presented and it turns
out that indeed if we look at
precipitation and this is now an
experiment where we are doing climate
engineering on top of an RCP 4.5
scenario so we're cooling down the
climate by about one degree and
nevertheless we we see many low large
grant languages with increased
precipitation in the blue here which
means that we're really suppressing it a
lot over ocean so there's this shift
from ocean to land so that's an
interesting aspect where the marine for
brightening so modifies the simple
picture I showed you before where we
just turned down the solar constant when
we got its overall reduction in the
hydrological cycle versus gluttony there
also some interesting and deviation from
that simple picture and first of all
this is a figure from through this paper
where we're looking at changing cloud
cover when you seed the cirrus clouds
and make them thinner so we see that
we're depleting the cloud amount here
and then and in this paper we did a much
simpler version of the true that it is
very carefully with state of the art or
even more than state of the art
Claud physics to simulate as actually as
possible the competition between
heterogeneous and homogeneous freezing
in this experiment we will wonder
whether one could just simulate this a
nice experiment by just manipulating ice
crystal fall speeds which is a recruit
way of doing that but the idea is that
if it works if it gets results similar
to this then that could be a cheap and
easy way to get many models involved and
studying surgical thinning it and it
seems that that's happening now people
are interested because at least if you
look at cloud cover it's it's similar so
in many ways even though the it
shortcuts all the appropriate physical
proxy for to get more people involved in
doing this experiment so so I'm going to
show you some more results of that
experiment and so this is the model we
were using and Kirk am-5 about one
degree resolution with slub ocean and we
have a control simulation and then we
have a simulation where he doubled the
full speed and then way another one
where we double it just in certain
regions and then you have one where did
the opposite where we reduce the fall
speed which would make the cirrus clouds
denser instead of thinner and here if we
look at the thinning x minus the
thickening experiment we see that that
we do get as desired we get a strong
reduction and long way cloud forcing so
and we also we do get also reduction and
in short i plot forcing but this effect
is much larger which is the global
average five point minus five point four
is plus two point four so it's
definitely cooling effect on the climate
system and and here's their the cooling
that we achieve and that experiment for
the at the surface with an Arctic
amplification and then here in the
troposphere with an air patrol trouble
troposphere Maxima so just the signature
of any like i said before after you run
more for many years the signatures
become
tentative the forcing that cost them but
in the beginning the nature of the force
thing is crucial so and we looked at
this a little bit more now on to
understand better what's happening to
the hydrological cycle and and as I
mentioned in my response to Ron's
question we have assumed that we can use
the first year as a proxy for the fast
response and whether the results are
strongly influenced by the nature of the
forcing and then an average of the last
ten years as indication of the response
the slow response so not only the
results for the first year and now I'm
going back to the equation i showed you
for the energy [ __ ] the atmosphere so
this must be showing you now the flux
diverting the radiative flux divergence
which is a source term for in the
equation for late in the sensible heat
and red are positive values and green a
blue and negative values so we see that
and this is when we are thinning the
cirrus clouds so we see where a lot of
red here and not so much green so we're
really we're really cooling the
atmosphere and when we cool the
atmosphere the atmosphere needs to
compensate for that but getting larger
turbulent fluxes from the surface of
sensible latent heat there's also a
storage turn across the admin even
although this is the first year there's
it's already certain to cool so that's
where these numbers don't quite match
but qualitatively this as a result of
that and then we get a precipitation
change which are not showing you but
which is consistent with this number and
if we do the opposite experiment where
we make the series close denser we'd get
exactly the opposite result we get a
negative flux diverges so we're now
warming the atmosphere and that will
lead to a reduction in the turbulent
fluxes if you like to think about in a
different way you can
think about it this way that you're
making you're enhancing the static
stability of the lower troposphere so
you get less convection it's another way
to think about it so you reduce the
turbulent of flux fluxes and you reduce
the precipitation and so that's the
first year let's just to understand the
energetics and then if we let the model
run and let the slow feedback start
influencing the results we can look at
what that does to the temperature and
the latent heat flux so latent heat flux
it's a proxy for for precipitation and
this is surface temperature so this is
what we just looked at the first year
and then for later years we start moving
along this line here with a lot of
scatter but we're moving this direction
so the temperatures start to cool
because we make the circulus thinner
we're letting a lot of heat outer space
so so because of the cooling
precipitation and the hydrological cycle
is suppressed but still and nevertheless
we see that even at one degree cooling
we still have a zero change in
precipitation compared to the original
experiment and that's because that's
because of what we saw here so the
nature of the forcing is important not
only the response yeah yeah yeah and
then this is when I do the opposite and
this is pretty much the mirror image of
what we just saw this is when we make
the surge cloud dancer and this is the
first year that I showed you before and
then we move along this line and we see
that if we look at this dashed line here
where it intersects the best fit line we
see that for even for a warming of about
point seven degrees there's no increase
in latent heat looks and that's because
we're warming the atmosphere by this
change of the cirrus clouds so it's not
just the temperature change that is
influencing the hydrological cycle
so to summarize and this relates to the
village I showed you that I hope I
convinced you that different climate
engineering techniques cause profoundly
different hydrological responses so we
cannot just apply as a general rule the
result we found for the simple
experiments where we turned on solar
constant they those results do not
necessarily apply to any particular
technique because they all have their
own inherent effect on the atmosphere
which we can understand from these
energetics perspectives as we saw for
solar constant reductions if you want to
maintain a constant temperature it will
inevitably employ a weaker hydrological
cycle because of the different
sensitivities to solar and co2 forcings
so this is this is not just a fluke this
is an inevitable result for more info
brightening yes that also you're also
reducing the solar constant or sorry the
solar input but you're only doing it our
ocean so things get a little bit more
mixed here and and we get this sort of
favorable side effect that there's a
tendency for moistening of the
low-latitude land regions so side
effects are not necessarily a bad thing
but it can be a bad thing of course in
case a circular thinning since it over
is in a long wave it avoids the non
consolation and it seems that maybe this
is a too strong term but it at least
according to what I just showed you it
avoids the suppression of the
hydrological cycle which makes it an
interesting idea but of course we should
keep in mind so we don't get carried
away here that some or even all of these
techniques may turn out to be
ineffective and or impossible to deploy
so this is currently this is all science
fiction all of these techniques
thank you